thank dick big day ding ding ding
welcome back to the Jimmy Julian podcast
aka the disturbed podcast aka the what
what why disturb down with the sickness
this week we have wonderful me in these
guys you've heard me talk about me on
these over and over and over again it's
the only underwear I wear ok if you
haven't tried them I don't know what in
the world you're waiting for but it
better be good man descends incredible
underwear with sustainably made
sustainably sourced material from
beechwood trees right to your door so
you know if to do anything just open
your door Beach wait why do I hear you
can you hear you Beach oh that's the oh
there we go it's better
oh I'll share a funny sorry about why
we're still doing this janky set up guys
twenty percent of your first pair at
Mandy's free shipping and satisfaction
guarantee when you go to me undies
comets Emmy UND IES na komm / Jenna
Julian
treat yourself you will not be sorry
honestly you guys also wink yo got a say
lately we've been drinking a lot of wine
wine badness and wink we are wired
dinosaurs wink makes it so much easier
to enjoy the wine that you love but
didn't know about before wink came into
your life
guys it's spelled winc okay
they make it easier to just discover new
wine because experts from wink select
wine match to your taste when you fill
out a taste flavor profile and they ship
it to your door and search was just $13
a bottle okay if you can't beat the
price and you should definitely give it
a try because the the wine that you're
gonna discover is limitless and also
something that you could probably never
have found by yourself mm-hmm
because you don't work for wink and you
don't even have to think about it you
just got wine a sore at your door mmm -
or at you don't um anyway we were
drinking a lot of wine because we have
like space to keep bottles of wine in
the house and it's so nice I like I've
always liked to drink wine yeah we've
never had one well I like one - yeah
you've been drinking wine yeah it's
really good no patios big one
it's good it's good yeah it's so nice to
just like have a glass of wine and be
like doesn't taste I agree with you wine
is good I mean the cold white wine I
like you know what I wanna I wanna start
branching up a wink let's get a little
adventurous here oh why are you talking
to her like that
dog dog I don't know how the audio is
for right now it's it's super
frustrating let me tell us what's
happening Julian okay when you move
there are quite literally hundreds of
things that you don't think about
setting up or taken care of or creating
ways to you know have the existing
amenities in your life fits your new
house weather weather you know whatever
your interests are like there's cable
there's the basic stuffs like cable
powered all that and then there's a
whole nother level of [ __ ] like you know
what services are we gonna need or was
sir what's our grocery routine or
whatever there's like a million things
that are happening one of the things
when we moved was okay we were
separating the podcast in the stream
room so we needed to like change our
equipment set up so we need to order a
PC for the podcast because just like a
basic PC to you know record the audio so
we're not doing it off of a little sound
recorder so I ordered this PC and
because there's a hundred things going
on and I'm getting emailed about this
and that you know every day I missed an
email I don't know how I missed but I
missed an email that came at the
beginning of May it's like right when we
were moving and what is they the email
said dear God don't let me bit
that's a hello Beach it said basically
because we are shipping address was
different than our billing address which
I'm sure a lot of you guys have tried
buying things with that situation before
and a lot of companies don't like that
so they were like because your billing
address is different than your shipping
address we can't ship your order we
can't ship your PC it's already built
but we can't we can't ship it to you and
I missed that so a month goes wrong
waiting for this piece I just think it's
gonna arrive like I man this sure is
taking a long time
so I've like literally like three days
ago I gone to my email you know what I
wonder what the status is with that and
I find literally to the date it was like
like May 17th or something like that
I checked it on June 7th or some [ __ ] or
15th or whatever and I was like you so I
responded I was like oh I'm so sorry for
the delay can you please send it to our
billing address or whatever and they're
like oh I'm sorry the window has passed
you didn't respond to time the orders
been cancelled
and I'm like oh my god no no no it's not
I'm so I you might need to talk a little
close here my emotions from this week
but basically I was like please please
can you please give me you know make the
order happen before it cancels because
otherwise if we had to redo the whole
order it would take so many more weeks
and luckily the customer service came in
clutch so they're sending it so they're
sending you know but so we're gonna have
a setup in here soon that's what oh my
god that's the idea we'll see if it
actually happens I don't know I kind of
get that it's good I thought it's a fee
like we're gonna be cutting out that
thing for a year it's possible I don't
even know how to operate that I don't
know how you do that you I don't know
it's easy to operate it's just it's like
not convenient for certain things
you're basically wild and out of control
okay you're a wine dinosaur yeah more
than a wine is soy - or - or can you
tell me what this is that we're doing
Julian was like hey for the podcast you
want to play a game called mommy can I
can't go and go out and kill tonight is
that what it is what like what is it so
I want I just felt in the mood to play
some sort of like adventure choose your
own choice adventure games online
because I think those are really fun and
they make for good content when you're
listening to a podcast as I've been
listening to more podcast lately
fine I have and I want to try to like do
stuff that I wanna listen to you know so
I think I feel like I choose your own
story is a good idea so I found this
website called choose your story calm
Oh play create share your own story
games so this is like a basically a hub
for if you want to play all sorts of
different themed Story games if you want
to post your story games if you want to
rate them if you want to review them
there's it's kind of like a big deal and
I was searching like a pop apocalyptic
like survival once and I was like oh
that's cool but then I found this one
that said mommy can I go out and kill
tonight and immediately I was I was
captivated
I'm Kal that title I'm ready what how
does it work it is a modern adventure by
Mac mad Glee that's the name of the user
who made it I can read the background
and the features but basically you start
it and then each moment each step or
whatever you're presented with options
what to do and you're choosing each
option which at the end of the story
will determine how you how you fared I'm
ready this story contains graphic
violence sexual images all situations oh
my god so it's just normal Jen Jillian
podcast oh my god you were a good boy
but then you turn bad no I'm a drug
addict cop cop killer manipulator these
are all names you could be called but
Leon helped you hide the evidence and
you were never cop for your crimes oh
you who are once so far gone yourself
now help others you take care of them
when no one else will
and yet the creature who who first
strayed from the path of righteousness
has not fully disappeared is still part
of you a dark psycho six cyclist is
threatening to get out you sometimes
hear it's voice at night whispering well
you try to fall asleep an eternal battle
between the dark and the light rages
within your mind which side will you
listen to during the most crucial of
days I feel raging it's like kinda like
the wolf among us it does feel like the
wolf among us all right I'm ready this
is an advanced game where you create a
character choose four of seven unique
traits and distributing a hundred points
between your three stats however you see
fit these stats do it I don't what's
just play just play mommy ,
can I go out and kill tonight
why are we talking to our mommy like me
mommy
mommy okay before you read before you
begin the story you need to create a
character character has three statistics
and four traits if this is your first
time reading this story please read all
the directions carefully before choosing
yeah yeah we'll skip them if you've read
the story before feel free to create
your character without reading any of
this okay statistics the stats are
endurance intellect and luck you may
modify these in any way you choose with
the points you are given but remember
endurance must always be at least 10
every stat is important and will play a
part throughout the story endurance this
stat represents your overall health
while combat is not the only feature in
the story it certainly plays a role a
character with an endurance of 10 is a
pale sickly creature who needs only to
be hit in the face to be knocked
unconscious or killed the character with
a hundred endurance it's pretty
difficult to kill outright but you can
still die or be incapacitated depending
on the players choices if your endurance
ever reaches zero you will die and the
story will be overall endurance directly
influences the traits of weapon master
and healer and plays a role with a trait
of bruiser intellect
this night represents how smart you are
intelligence involves memory cognition
knowledge and among other things a
character with an intellect of 10 is a
complete [ __ ] barely able to multiply 5
by 10 a character with a hundred
intellect can do advanced calculus
equations in his or her head while
discussing astrophysics intellect will
never change throughout the story
although when while the stat will not
obviously kill you by reaching zero it
plays a significant role in your success
or failure in many actions throughout
the story and I like directly influences
the traits of the pharmacist diplomat
and the role with the trait of psychic
Luck this stat represents how lucky you
are lucky plays a mysterious role
throughout the story but should not be
disregarded as unimportant many times in
the story mmm sorry many times the story
will roll a random number without your
knowledge and luck will play a crucial
role in the outcome
so there's RNG involved a character with
ten luck is so unlucky that even when he
walks outside his house he's likely to
be run down by a truck a character with
a hundred luck and nearly do anything
without fear of reprisal however every
time you specifically use your luck the
step decrease oh so it has a lifespan is
a very important point to remember luck
directly influences the traits of street
smart and psychic and plays a role with
the trade of bruiser it also plays a
small role with every other tree ok now
we pick our trait we can only pick four
ok you may only pick four bruiser you
are extremely strong when given the
choice you will hit much harder when you
hit someone in combat however the
strength comes with a recklessness that
will cause your strikes to be slightly
less accurate while not dominated by any
statistic both luck and endurance play a
part when using this trait
diplomat you know how to talk fast
articulately and equally good and you
are equally good in persuading and
bluffing others this trait can get you
out of many difficult situations
diplomacy is not the same as street
smart and will not always work with
those you might consider undereducated
intellect is most important when using
this trait healer you're able to heal
yourself by regaining lost endurance
points you cannot use this trait
whenever you want but it can be
invaluable during parts of the story
when you have chance you have a chance
to regain your loss and dirt
Endurance's most employment using this
trade pharmacist you can identify any
pharmaceutical or herb including illegal
substances this knowledge gives you the
upper hand when figuring out a
particular subject whether a particular
substance is dangerous benign or even
useful in situations you might not
otherwise be able to determine in
Alexa's most important in this tray six
cents you're able to you were extremely
intuitive in many situations when the
right choice is not clear your six cents
will enable you to pick correctly
avoiding many unpleasant outcomes
furthermore you can determine other
players I started you can determine
another's intentions far more easily
such as when they are lying or wish you
harm Lucky's most important using this
trade but in the light plays a part
street smart you know how to get around
the urban sprawl without getting conned
mugged or outright beaten utilizing
skills you have learned from a long stay
in New York City and you can talk your
way or fight your way out of many
situations in st. Louis you will
otherwise have to face street smart is
not the same as diplomat but it will
always work with those you might
consider educated luck is most important
using this tray weapon master you're an
expert with WEP any weapon you come upon
in addition to your already expert
hand-to-hand training any weapon you
wield be it a katana or a pencil will
become deadly in your hands endurance is
most important ministry okay it's also
important to know that there are four
statistics you cannot choose your change
these are that your level of psychosis
your psychedelic state your level of
sobriety and score will all be modified
depending on your choices throughout the
story so those are out of your control
okay so let's pick right radar character
okay well this is cool you just like
what are you doing oh okay so I'd only
talk about our traits what kind of
traits you want in the mole divvy up our
endurance and in elective okay um I
think that if we do something physical
something using our brain and then
something like sixth sense or healer or
pharmacists you mean yeah I say weapon
master is a little better at than
bruiser because weapon master only
requires endurance bruiser requires luck
and endurance and there's also a
downside to bruiser which is you're
you're you're kind of shots yeah yeah so
I say weapon master for a physical
what okay that sounds good weapon master
yeah
wait you need to go back what happened
wait what oh I accidentally okay so we
have to we have to do the traits first
oh [ __ ]
otherwise it'll just end the story okay
okay so we have to yeah that was the
problem all right
endurance so see it says must be at
least 10 to continue so we needed a
Durance plus 10
okay so endurance is 10 okay but we have
a hundred points I know I think we have
to divvy on that before we okay trades
go for it
okay so let's do intellect 10 mm-hmm
locked mm-hmm
but but just think about our traits and
then you'll add a module there yeah yeah
so scroll down I'd say for weapon master
that requires endurance so we're
probably looking at spending at least 30
points into ender and cool let's add 10
more so with 30 endurance and then I
think they should be relatively even
right yeah 30 30 30 want to just do that
yeah and then we'll add a little more to
what we think
making a pretty balanced person each
yeah we're super balanced you know
I mean this isn't really how I would
divvy up my champion points and elders
okay so we have 10 extra points where do
we put them um well we're 30 33 got it
why don't you go down and look at the
traits so we can pick them but not you
don't have to click on yeah you can
count on luck and endurance so I know
I'm just looking ice a diplomat is
pretty good healer is pretty sorry I
can't really hear you you're talking to
the side of your mic I'm sorry do you
want to play the games I need to be able
to hear your guard Diplomats pretty good
healer is pretty good pharmacist
six-inch street-smart I'd say six cents
is valuable pharmacists is valuable
healer so we definitely need endurance
so that I'd say it looks like most of
those are on luck and intellect the
thing is about endurance as it decreases
throughout the story so use luck and
intellect or you're saying we need more
I would say we need more endurance that
because we're preparing for it to just
go down why don't you go 40 30 30
we can also add by ones - okay 35 all
right 1 2 3 4 5 ok now we have 5 points
left
let's do to luck 3 and elect how's that
yeah that's good
two three done okay
it's a weapon master yep
what was the other one house six hands
or street smart
why don't you pick one it's your
diplomat okay so your diplomat weapon
master six cents I'd say or street smart
I like this because he uses both okay
and then I'd say either healer or
pharmacist - healer what
okay so we're
we have everything picked character
created cool let's do it each where we
go now
okay sorry um
when you're finished click character
created begin the background
do you have more points to add or
something
I don't know
all right this needs to equal hundred to
continue right -
oh this is what yeah let me see one
hundred out of a hundred this needs to
equal harder to continue
don't you hit save or you're at 110 no
no you know
order were save up at the top right
okay
oh no it's it's like one let us go go
through
[Music]
save okay
sorry um you know sorry okay
intellect let's try to I don't know
I don't know why it's doing this this is
weird you're still at 110 I know but
like it doesn't
all right we figured it out time to go
um begin the background right yep
you weren't always a problem child until
age 15 you were the epitome of good
straight A's no mind-altering substances
and a full scholarship to a progress
right no that part's not right but okay
depends means however you hated nearly
everyone around you so you transfer to a
public school used your wire I don't
like to assembly in the in crowds values
your good looks determine women and
start you Oh ladies whoa every hot girl
in your school like to you every jock
hate you but god damn they respect you
you smoked weed by day and [ __ ] a
different cheerleader by night oh my god
oh my god this story is graphic you were
a god oh my god College came and went in
a blur but you scored trade it straight
A's in those years the drugs got harder
and your friends got rougher trouble
came with two cops trying to bust you
for possession distribution but you took
care of that handcuffed them with their
own tools and shot on both in the back
of the head your friend Leon helped bad
guys Jason Derulo go ahead your friend
Leon helped you dispose of their corpses
Wow neither of you were ever caught
years past me became a shell of your
former self shooting heroin and cocaine
intent on nothing but blissful oblivion
you almost died your brother saved you
from this hell and your mind convulsed
with the revelation and possibility of
self-actualization returning to school
you got a doctorate in science
specializing in psychiatry psychiatry
and nursing you were so far who were so
far gone now help people you take care
of them and no one else will and even
when and even one are you okay what Wow
what are you talking about I'm just
reading No
and yet the first sorry and yet the guy
who first strayed from the path of
registered here ed all that okay all
right to which side will you listen
during this most crucial of days all
right wake up it's our only choice we
gotta wake up ready to wake up something
awakens you you're not sure what
something is it doesn't matter all that
matters is you're awake it's 9:00 on a
Friday morning you have rounds at the
hospital Stacy's lying beside you who
arms slung across your chest and moans
as you surreptitiously attempt to free
yourself without waking her knew you
stride to your bathroom and throw up
throw yourself throw out yourself into
the shower hot water blast your face and
then figure Eight's you you soap up and
try to forget you got maybe four hours
of sleep most of the night of vague
recollection images of creep unbidden
into your consciousness images of creep
images of crete that's a weird sentence
stacy bent over on the bed on the balls
of her feet you thrusting into her oh my
god don't read any of that don't read
any of that is porn are ya oh my god
actually gonna skip that that's so extra
wow you fit a showering drought for the
fluffy green bath towel and put in new
content porn take fifty milligrams of
[ __ ] boost prong boost Baroni boosts
perón buspirone II I don't know
buspirone and a multivitamin brush your
teeth and get a drink of water cover the
tattoos with TaylorMade thousand dollar
black pinstripe soup and bright lime
green silk tie stacy opens her eyes
momentarily smiles sleepily then shifts
her stomach and pulls the covers over
her head bring home some leather
restraints you hear her mumble you laugh
outright
okay now we have the options to enter
the kitchen enter the computer room into
the bathroom go to work we gotta go to
work let's just skip it all go to work
yeah each leaving your house you lock
the front door and smile ruefully at the
back at the black 2005 Scion x8 you've
customized the thing with tinted windows
and a bazooka subwoofer for sure oh
we're a [ __ ] huh yeah we sound like the
worst person ever it's small and not the
fastest car in the world but it gets
thirty-six miles a gallon handles great
and you can parallel park the thing
anywhere all for 13,000 measly bucks
some people think you're 6-3 170 pound
frame is a bit too big for the ride but
they're wrong comfortable and stable
gets you where you need to go to the
right of your apartment there's a
walkway which leads to a dumpster in the
alley you hope you didn't forget
anything because you won't be coming
back here for quite a while we can drive
to the hospital go back inside or follow
the walkway I don't want to go to a
dumpster in the alley you didn't you
hope you didn't forget anything okay so
we just go through the work I don't want
to go to a dumpster I'm a douche bag and
I'm wearing a very expensive suit that
just did porn didn't do porn I did porn
do it we just really graphically
described our night hey you guys must
you should be happy we didn't read that
you're on the road doing 40 down Kings
Highway you pass a quick trip on your
right Uncle Bill's pancake house on your
left and a multitude of car dealerships
on both side highway 40 is coming up
fast you signal you merge you accelerate
65 nice keying the stereo to your
favorite 90s music confessions of a
knife the thrills the thrill kill Kult
source album comes on you left as you
hear the sampled Joanne Joanne [ __ ] I'm
gonna find her and I'm gonna kill her
blaring through the car and a standard
200 watt surround system the subwoofer
you added in the small interior to allow
music to resonate filling you with sound
all of that is extra glancing in the
rearview mirror you see red and blue
flashing lights a mother [ __ ] pigs
you in Bertinelli mutter pulling you
over pulling over four and wait for the
cop to approach okay
are you and you one choice it's just
being an agitated state of mind
let's get agitated agitated you watch
the cop in the rearview mirror he's
talking to his radio calling in your car
images return you the handcuffed cops
they first pleading in bargaining then
going silent as you fighter the
forty-five semi-auto point-blank in the
back wad
he's flashback to when he killed the cop
Oh God okay it was like this escalated
so fast
what is going on quarter-sized holes in
the posterior skull fragments and
anterior explosions above the right eye
half their faces gone absolutely pieces
of brains sprayed about the background
yeah bright red red blood flashing onto
the pavement like Jack like a Jackson
Pollock painting dark red afterwards
sleeping oh my god this is so graphic
right the sudden realization that you
killed another human and not any human a
[ __ ] cop judges and juries tend to
execute cop killers you were afraid the
disturbing thing is that fear outweighed
any guilt you might have otherwise felt
well what about the children if cops can
get up if cops can get it up oh my god
can they even procreate did the
innocence wonder about their dads
absence did they did conceive of
horrible realities their tiny Minds
couldn't verbalize did they simply ask
eyes wide with puckered cheeks
where's daddy isn't he coming home mommy
dad what can she really say that's our
only choice why don't you tell them what
the choices are the choice is what can
she really say okay her answer wait this
is so this is all just like mind I don't
know okay fraid rub clenched her body
her the significance that her husband
didn't call to say he was going late
perverse thoughts that she married a
[ __ ] cop realization that the kind of
this kind of [ __ ] was bound to happen
meant to happen maybe even if she asked
for it doomed her kids by accepting the
late hours the violence the danger but
how could she respond no PD he's not
daddy daddy finally enforced the law in
the wrong place at the wrong time [ __ ]
with the wrong person his vanity and
overconfidence precluded basic
self-preservation in costume and so he
died a brutal death there'll be a
funeral with guns fired into the air and
unison salutes the whole hack nudge
[ __ ] shebang you'll be the male child
sitting next to the casting like like a
perverse colored recreation of John John
and Jack live with it I always have and
the memory of the corpse is slowly
sinking beneath the putrid waters of
these river
their eyes glassy staring at you with
unspoken accusation the abruptness of
their these unbidden images startles you
and you and induces emotional NAHASDA
nausea can this pig see into your soul
irrational nonsense you think wiping a
bead of sweat from your forehead well I
want this prick hurry up so that was all
just like him living like reliving all
that in his head when he got pulled over
well I don't this prick hurry up you
wonder I'm late I'm late I'm late you
feel yourself getting and we angry both
off of nervousness and a basic loathing
basic loathing for authority this
bastards gonna make you late and you did
nothing you feel like telling him to
piss off so you can either wait for the
cop to approach or speed away and try to
lose his ass
let's get live come on can we please
speed alright speed away go ahead
there's only two choices like I would
wait for the cop but if you want to
speed away let's speed away you ever
dangerous Aries do what you want see
this is this is this was bound to happen
what we come to a head here where
there's an Aries choice there's a Virgo
choice go ahead speed away
shoving the stick shift in the first
you've got it the Scion moves forward
but not with any high-pitched whine our
low growl you'd expect from a sports car
rather it sort of eases them to traffic
acceleration is almost nil
nevertheless you managed to hit 85
before three-car cars are right behind
you sirens wailing and their red and
blue lights reflecting off you mirrors
your Laden foot slams down the gas and
the Scion cross to a hundred after about
20 seconds one squad car pulls up to
your left the other two remain behind
you glance over and see the cop is
grinning what do you do do you turn hard
smashing your car into his pull over and
give up if you wish to use your sixth
sense trade click here all right let's
use our sixth sense trade ok
your intuition tells you two things
first the cop is a better driver than
you second your car is much smaller
lighter and more fragile than his trying
to smash him wouldn't be very very very
foolish and probably result in your
death however the decision is yours to
make
well now you can either pull over or
smash his car that's in really it did
because if we had smash we would have
died mm-hmm interesting pull over and
give up good thing we sped away am i
right ladies enough you think there's no
possible waking out on these cops so you
may as well pull over and get what's
coming to you you pull over now we're in
extra trouble Julian it was worth the
attempt oh you shut off the engine the
cop that was to your left squeals to a
stop in front of your car the two behind
you pull up next to you and directly
behind respectively all three cops get
out of their cars guns drawn and descend
upon you hands on the wheel [ __ ]
the first one shouts you obey the cops
open the door grab you by the neck
throwing you on the pavement
we didn't need to do this cops around
you you impatient Aries you're prone
body and scream in unison don't move you
guys stay absolutely still they begin
bludgeon you with their nightsticks and
yelling he's trying to escape he'd be
baffled by this behavior if you weren't
quickly approaching unconsciousness when
the beatings finally end they handcuff
you and officer piles roughly sure
searches your batter battered flesh he
finds doesn't find anything that's the
only choice
officer piles fists you and finds
nothing more value to him you want
wonder what the hospital not to mention
the doctors will think when you start
showing up for late rounds you he starts
writing a ticket Oh a ticket the least
of your worse okay that's the wrong
option an $80 ticket oh we can look at
it oh I kept it an ER ticket you're
gonna have to call your attorney and pay
him 200 to fix this thing okay get
arrested
that's our only choice sir only soraa's
get arrested all right so now we're
arrested this is crazy
are you how are you feeling like this is
crazy I feel like we didn't need to get
arrested
satisfied and sweating profusely sir
piles pulls you and pulls you up and
leads you to a squad car he roughly
pushes you in in your head smashes
against the roof after that beating he
almost passed out from that last blow
you're under arrest for leaving the
scene and resisting arrest you have the
right to suck my [ __ ] when I ask and the
right to get your teeth kicked in if you
refuse they seem like a cool I gave you
the option keep going
you will remain wisely silent perhaps
you've been impulsive enough for one day
the handcuffs are chafing your wrist the
cop gets back on the highway makes a
u-turn gets off taking you the Richmond
Heights Police Station do you sit there
and wait for the inevitable or thrash
about wildly screaming obscenities all
times
no more Ares decision no I mean it might
cause some sort of distraction you know
stop it that's disgusting I don't want
to flail in the back of a cop car sit
there waiting for an inevitable good we
sit there and wait you did this officer
Powell shoves you into the station
causing you to stumble momentarily your
earlier rage has been so planed by fear
of the unknown and you've never actually
been arrested the cop takes off your
handcuffs and you feel relieved you rub
your sore wrist and try to get the red
lines to go away he grabs your hand and
starts fingerprinting you first your
thumb then all your fingers phone rings
and you hear a dispatcher in another
room call out the location of a crime
you're you serve a your surroundings
besides officer piles no one else is
present there are a bunch of cubicles
through a door to your left a row of
holding cells to your right and a break
room straight ahead thinking finish
fingerprinting you officer piles grabs
your time and starts walking you the
holding cells do you think you have a
good chance of shaking him and running
off so you choose maybe even gaining
tangible goods in the process but you
get a little more but you may get a
little more psychotic all right you have
four options here five options you try
to break free free and run to the
cubicles do you try to break free and
run to the break room do you try to
break free and run to the holding cells
and you try to break free and run to the
exit or you can let them lead you to the
holding cells initial thoughts here
follow the rules there's four options
okay then you pick I don't want to pick
the bad stuff am I good at picking bad
decisions let's let's use our sixth
sense no that's not a choice
pick one well what do you get if you are
under the cubicles what's the best thing
you could find a stapler the word about
the break room um food food holding
cells holding cells where you're getting
taken to so that wouldn't make sense to
run to the home or you can just run out
the exit which that's stupid I think
well let's run to like the cubicles or
the break room I think cubicles because
there's a lot of places to hide okay
let's do it all right we're under the
cubicles you run for the cubicles to
your left out of your peripheral vision
you see the exit door open up in two
cops enter they see you immediately
around towards you while officer Pyle
screams get him and gives chase running
into the room you slam the heavy wooden
door it's tiny glass window filled with
chicken wire presumably for safety the
lock clicks and you observe all three
cop cops fumbling with their keys you
haven't much time glancing around you
see a door in the north wall pass one
cubicle to the west lies a pseudo maze
of cubicles if you're going to act do it
now you can lie down and let them take
you around north to the door or west of
the cubicles cubicles okay go for it the
cubicles open north towards another
cubicle east towards the middle cubicle
leading to where you were fingerprinted
and south to a lone cubicle the cops
still after you and are screaming the
ubiquitous freeze whatever you do you
better do it quick you can run south to
the lone cubicle east to the middle
north to the northwest or lie down with
them take you
pick one let's go north the cubicle is
plain and uncluttered the desk is nice
and tidy the carpet is vacuumed and
there are no pictures to be seen
you can go east towards the north
cubicle that's so confusing or return
south from where you once came of course
you still hear the cops and they sound
very close let's go east so towards the
north cubicle ok a large wooden door
sits on the north wall a desk sits right
in front of you and the solidarity red
chair sits right behind it
solitary what am I saying on the surface
of the desk is a small assignment reads
register all evidence with officer on
duty obviously this isn't any ordinary
cubicle it's some sort of a sort of
guard station albeit empty no wonder the
cops seem like a bunch of Keystone's
they can't even man this desk whatever
is behind the door must be of relative
importance I think we should run through
that door let's do it silver metal
shelves lining lines three of the dirty
concrete walls most shelves containing a
plethora of boxes and items bagged in
clear plastic evidence room an old fat
old room print fan grumbles with its
duty directly in front of you presumably
the storage room is a shoddy replacement
for an evidence hold there are no guards
at most I didn't seem to be missing any
sort of label a square sign has been
taped to long shelves
but there is no sign of the third or
fourth each sign has a block letters
printed on it
black on in black ink the first sign
says aah 8h the second sentence is cute
is easy you assume one shelf without a
sign is I through P but you have no idea
what the fourth shelf is it seems bare
also you see a door on the east and
south wall you have no time to mess
around so what do you do you can check
out a through H I through PQ through Z
you can look through the evidence or you
can check out the fourth unlabeled shelf
you can run out the east or south or let
the cops get you why don't you check out
that fourth unlabeled shelf I mean I
know we're in a hurry but like that's a
good idea yeah this long shelf is devoid
of anything save a good of save a good
bit of dust you cannot determine why the
other shelves have plenty of items while
this main shelf is completely bare you
what you can't determine however is that
at least three pissed-off cops are
trying to catch you you hear them
approaching alright we can examine the
rest of the soldier okay just look at
one of them a through H yeah let's do it
oh [ __ ] yeah you search the shelves and
find a box cutter lying oh okay wait a
weapon has to be lying next to a cane
and a [ __ ] suit the only only the box
cutter looks useful as you already walk
with a steady gait and you aren't into
deviant sexual behavior well you're not
into it that much besides it's a wicked
looking box cutter that appears to have
extremely extremely sharp blade
meanwhile you hear the cops approaching
all right we can keep examining that's
the only choice it does examine the rest
of the storage and it takes you back to
this let's go I through P I through P an
old suede bowler hat and pencil catch
your eye on the shelf but you don't
either those the rest of the room Q
through Z yeah an old pair of
rollerblades catches your eye at first
you wonder what if you could skate away
from the cops faster than running then
you haven't skated then you realize you
haven't skated in years there's a metal
wrench next to the rollerblades
it's rub yellow rubber grips and strong
jaws look perfect for twisting and
turning and well wrenching you hear the
cops approaching we already checked out
all the shelves now we can run to the
east door or the south door
okay let's go east Oh God we're in the
break [ __ ] four cops are sitting in this
room drinking coffee and gorging
themselves full of Krispy Kreme
Doughnuts one particularly obese cop has
his right hand in his pants and
voraciously scratching his genitals with
a sigh of relief nice just then however
the cops chasing you burst into the room
and officer pauls yells you idiot don't
you hear us this bastard has been
running around the station trying to
escape
officer piles heaves with exhaustion and
his face nearly purple he grabs at his
left arm for the four cops stand up
oh yeah so when you walked in the those
guys didn't seem to notice you the four
cop stand up but their face is only
registered confusion as though the
message hasn't set in yet you calmly
survey the room barely out of breath
despite your run and consider your
options as you do so officer pilots
collapse to the floor
- cops notice this fact with horror go
help him oh because he just like passed
out the other four have now encircled
you know as you see it you can either
lie down and let them take you try to
fight your way out or run like hell this
would be the most strategic place to
fight but you need a decent weapon to
overcome the odds and even then you'd
most likely have to kill one or more of
the cops so you can start swinging if
you have the cops gun click here okay we
don't dodge the cops and run through the
West door - your cops are under this
house door lie down and let them take
you we have the box cutter yeah but
that's not a choice that says dodge the
cops and run is probably our best option
cuz start singing start swinging says
start swinging question mark oh it does
have a question mark damn we didn't get
any of the cops guns how could we have
done that I don't know you better start
running boy alright let's go through the
snow west door well we're back in the
storage area we're back in this
direction so let's go through the south
door okay a large wooden door sits to
the north wall a desk sits right in
front of you with it oh this is the same
how do we get out god I'm stuck
run to the north door
back in the storage room south door its
amazed by you gotta figure it out that's
cubicle
the cubicle is plain an uncluttered oh
[ __ ] run through the West cubicle keep
going my god dude
I'm at the middle cubicle
dude I'm like getting I keep looping
around through these through three
cubicles or north
oh we got caught the cops catch up to
you when you run to the north cubicle
who you are running from the cops
chasing you and you mess around and take
too long the cops burst from every
direction and roughly tackle you damn it
mm-hmm okay well you get taken to
holding
the holding cells this is this is hard
man the cop unlocks the steel door right
in front even it opens it on creaking
hinges you brought into a long hallway
line on either sides by holding cells
groups of prisoners lounge and mouths of
them most of them staring at you through
the bar without surprise an enormous
cro-magnon skin head emits a deep laugh
as you're dragged by his hand reaches
through the bars his bicep easily
doubling the diameter of your head his
shoulders plastered with a black
swastika and ropey muscles of his
forearm tattoo but the words laying
leavened two fewer the black ink blurs
as you pass so he's just a Nazi in jail
and the cops beat at his hand with their
nightstick causing him to withdraw it
see you have no time to decipher its
meaning the hallway is a dead end at an
impenetrable concrete wall they open
yourself to the right throw you in and
lock the door behind you okay you can
look around yourself oh my god how long
is this this is crazy I have no idea you
asked me if I wanted to play a game
called mommy can I go out and kill
tonight I know it's crazy you look
around warily the cell is a square plain
concrete with no windows the bench lines
two of the walls and the far one is this
stopped up you're overflowing there are
no windows given the space a drab
colourless depressing air you occupy the
cell the first two people two people I'm
sorry I'm like reading a lot this is
getting like the first is it held early
black man sitting on the bench with his
eyes closed the other is a skinny
Hispanic standing right to the right
value neural urinal arms folded across a
shirtless chest glaring me the way he's
staring at you is a bit alarming you can
talk to the black man you can sit down
by yourself talk to the Hispanic man or
examine the euro let's talk to a black
man you walk up and say hello his eyes
remain closed he doesn't respond get the
[ __ ] away from him you hear the Hispanic
say you repeat yourself still the man
doesn't show any sign he's heard you I
said get the [ __ ] away from him the
Hispanic man takes a menacing step
towards you suddenly recall that you
were wearing a very expense
I'll be it rumpled and dirty after your
ordeal all your training dictates that
you walk away or try to calm him calming
him seems unlike you unlikely what seems
likely is that you're about to get
punched in the nose for your suit maybe
you're being too docile showing weakness
by minding your own business maybe you
should get verbally abusive and turn
maybe you should even add an ethnic slur
oh no walk away and sit down by yourself
or tell piss off Blanc before I got you
sit down well we have to establish some
sort of ailments down uh okay we sit
down better not cause troubles sit down
wait for the cops to give you your phone
call you post bail and get the hell out
of there there's no clock anywhere
within view but you realize it must be
later than 10 excuses start flooding
your mind ways to explain your lateness
your thoughts are really interrupted by
it or when is it how do you say that I
don't know
I have voice you what you're too good
for me you look up and see this panic
standing over you nice suit Holmes he
looks at you meaningfully all your
training dictates that you walk away
that's the same thing tell him piss off
or ignore him and hope he goes away
ignore him
not saying that word you pay no
attention you look at the floor avoiding
eye contact hoping he'll go away leave
ET Missourian excuses hey you he shoves
your shoulder you still ignore him you
know who I am he leans in minion screams
your ear you deaf [ __ ] seconds
later your lift to do a standing
position and you're not a small guy he
pushes you down on the cold floor cell
standing up
standing up you brushed your suit off
and try to sit back down all the while
maintaining an air of indifference
that's when he comes for you you're
beating awaits that's our only choice is
our beating awaits yeah he backhands you
across the face much like the cops did
the slap stings just as much a
millisecond later he punches you square
in the eye knocking you to the ground
your face smashes into the hard concrete
of the floor knocking a lute knocking
loose' filling and engaged your you turn
but he's already on you punching you
once twice three times in the face this
panic grabs you by the throat with both
hands beating at his hands does no good
this bastard is much stronger than he
looked you struggle and gasp for breath
leave that boy alone CJ the soft voice
comes from your left but you can barely
hear it you can't breathe you feel
yourself losing consciousness
leave him alone I said the hands relax
their grip you grasp for air like a fish
flopping uselessly on land as your
vision clears you see the voice come
from the back oh sorry you see the voice
came from the black man CJ is standing
over you fists clenched but a moment
later he backs away our only choice says
lucky you saved from certain death you
slowly get up from the hard concrete
floor and rub your neck still breathing
heavily the black man looks up and says
you smart but timid boy mind in your
business don't get you killed as fast
but CJ wasn't gonna let you be he stands
up and you regard him with ambivalence
his face looks vaguely familiar but you
have no idea where you would have seen
him his hair is a wild fray his clothes
dirty his stink reaches you from here
and you wonder how you didn't smell it
before with one hand he scratches his
stubble chin the hand is scarred beyond
belief thick pinkish lines stacked on
top of normal tissue make it look like a
malformed Club you know me yes you
remember now who could forget that hand
yes you say you were in the hospital
because you wanted to kill yourself
right boy that's right he slaps his
thigh with the meat hand and moves
closer you know insurance remember I
remember and you knew I was about to
kill my [ __ ] self right you
consider thinking back I knew yes
but you let me stay anyways that week
was hot maybe 105 degrees for three days
in a row and shelters are often full I
did see J cracks his knuckles to your
right
you notice he's standing almost behind
you and you didn't get [ __ ] for that his
breath is fetid like old sardines I
didn't get paid if that's what you mean
the man looks satisfied he smiles and
sits back down with a look from him CJ
moves away from you and sits on the
opposite bench didn't think so the
Blackman says thoughtfully names lamonta
sit down I want to talk to you doesn't
look like you have a choice our only
choices doesn't look like you have a
choice you sit down next to him as he
requested he just stares at you with a
smile on his face minutes pass you hear
the skinhead from down the block yelling
something incomprehensible gave you a
break because you gave me one what's
your name Dominic you were playing who
are names Dominic
Oh fine good name is any he says what
you're doing here looking like you do
you explain the circumstances leading up
to your arrests and he laughs CJ snorts
nice moves boy sounds like you ain't as
smart as you look
you let the comment go he's probably
right show me what you got in your
pockets show you show him everything you
have besides those things you got
anything else
our only choice says nope nothing
nothing else glad you was straight with
me Dominic he looks over at CJ we don't
tolerate no lying [ __ ] up in
here you straighten your suit jacket and
wait for him to speak again lamonta
leans over and whispers I got a
proposition for you ignoring this
sinking feeling that this is some sort
of filthy godfather about to make you an
offer you can't refuse especially in a
confined space you reply I'm listening
okay okay listen here first off you
ain't gonna get a phone call so you
ain't gettin outta here tonight
he coughs
I don't know what that word is then
continue awesome payphones broken it's
Friday they'll hold your ass till Monday
you don't get bailed out his information
sets in two more days in the cells Stacy
we'll get really worried and you'll get
fired for being a no-show Miranda rights
violated because the payphones broken
not possible not possible you consider
pounding on the bar skin a cop's
attention I know what you're thinking
they don't care they'll sit they'll say
you smashed up some phone or some [ __ ]
smashed up the phone or some [ __ ] I'm
but I'm in with one of them owes me a
favor he'll let you use the station
phone you got someone to call yeah my
girlfriend you mumble lamonta smiles you
know she'll answer I think so yeah okay
good that's real good now he's the
proposition I get the cop to let you use
the working phone you call your woman he
watches your eyes right you could get
out of here tonight I only want one
thing in return
what's that you'll hold your breath
certain he's going to demand you pay
CJ's bail or for an attorney to let him
sit order to let him stay with you when
I get out I want you to call this number
he passes you a tiny slip of white paper
scrawled in pencil are the numbers three
one four or five nine four two or nine
six Isaac will answer tell him Ella's
got taken down in Richmond Heights
finish the deal then hang up think you
can do that Webb boy do you have access
to a phone why can't you just call the
number you Riley asked because those
[ __ ] cops been listening I
can't have that gotta be definitely
outside now you're gonna do it or not
you make the mental note of the phone
number and the name consult your
character sheet if you need to remember
so you'd say oh okay I'll do it or you
say no I'm getting and keep trying to
get in the cops attention I say we do it
let's do it seems like the best option
okay
you evaluate his posture expression in
eyes and you don't sense any dishonesty
you're quite a good judge besides the
way the cops have treated you in the
past couple hours led you to believe
that you may never get out of the cell
LeMond taste proposition might be your
only way out I'll do it give me a phone
all right just remember you [ __ ] me on
this one I'll find you you don't doubt
he would or at least his friends would
neither would be good lamonta cashes in
a favor
walking up to the bars lamonta calls out
yo Stine you have expected skinhead to
yell out mockingly but he doesn't
instead you hear heavy footsteps of a
cop officer Stein walks up to the bars
glances at you back at Lamont a what do
you want want a well my friend here
pointing at you to make his phone call
officer pals won't like it I don't give
a [ __ ] what pals likes man give this man
his phone call reluctantly officer Stein
nods his head
you wonder what lamonta did for him
because that that would cause this
obedience opening the cell door the cop
points you in the direction of the phone
falls right behind you you hear him
whisper you tell me what you're doing
for lamonta and I'll tear up that ticket
let you out right now hohoho
what do you what do you say glancing me
right you see the skinhead sullenly look
at you eyes like tiny black calls
lamonta couldn't hear from where he was
ok so basically the cop is offering the
free you right back no snitch
if you snitch snitches get stitches I
don't think we snitch
no snitching okay so our offers refuse
and let him lead you to the phone or
tell officer Stein what he wants them eh
we go to the phone
refuse phone is sitting in a desk or
your fingerprint officer Stein points to
it says two minutes and he crosses his
arms and stares at you expectantly you
pick up the phone quickly dial home the
phone rings once twice three times
answer baby answer please you mutter on
the fifth ring she answers hello Stacy
it's me oh hi Petey eyes work you hear
her close the refrigerator door actually
maybe I'm not at work I got arrested
arrested what the hell happened I don't
have time to explain
this my only phone call I barely got
even got to make it I need you to come
to the Richmond Heights station to bail
me out it's right off 14 off on bail of
you okay I'll be right up see you soon
she hangs up so intelligent this one
great sense of humor but knows when to
get serious and I get things done a
strong woman and you're lucky to be with
her great sense of direction too unlike
you who just lost five minutes from your
house you have no doubt she'll be there
to bail you within the next 15 minutes
Stein leads you back to yourself that's
her only option
sign says all right you got your phone
call you sure you don't want to tell me
what you're doing for Lamont a you shrug
in wisely remain silent wisely wisely
wisely wisely he leads you back to
yourself opens it slams the door shut
behind you hope Stacy has $1,500
that's your bail angry he walks away
once the cop is gone Lamont he grabs him
how'd it go boy grabs your arm how'd it
go what well Stacy's on her way you sit
back down on the bench Lamont a sits
next to you and CJ still standing at the
urinal with a peculiar but the peculiar
gleam in his eye Lamont he says it's
time try to shake you down you not
thought so and you didn't say [ __ ] good
man you made the right decision Dominic
don't forget to make that phone call
hell yeah I won't
Stacy arrives is their only option less
than 10 minutes later two cops you don't
recognize approach one the cell one
opens up the door the other stands to
the side hands on his gun sink you made
bail out r'mante looks into your eyes
his blood shot in a matter of factly
I held up my end boy don't [ __ ] with me
you leave the cell you walk away you
glance over your shoulder and see Lamont
say clenching the bars watching you you
go meet up with Stacy you step outside
and it's beginning to get dark thanks
for coming so fast that was the worst
you give her a long kiss on the mouth no
problem now tell me what the hell how
both of you walk towards the car it's
been released from lockup and it's
parked on the side of the station
telling her everything everything
leaving out no detail she registers only
shock is all that true or are you
exaggerating
usually do you saw unfortunately I'm not
exaggerating Jesus paid both you in the
past couple of hours both of you allow
the past couple hours of said and she
says so now what you're gonna call that
number what time is it five o'clock she
states I don't think he should call it I
don't they don't know who you are you
think about the statement for a while
actually I told that guy my first name
and when the cops let me out they said
my last name she looks at you for a
while her mouth slightly open and says
oh no in in the lip in the it be a
comical except it be comical except for
your situation I know look what God did
you scratch your head okay so you can
make the call you can forget it you can
make the call and go home okay so you
make the call go to the hospital forget
the call go to the hospital make the
call go home forget the call go
as even make the colander work yeah
let's do that
I'm going to make the call then I have
to get to the hospital you say all right
good luck maybe call me later tell me
what happened she kisses you and leaves
you at your car you get in your car and
drive out of the station head back to
the highway there's a phone by the
hospital you can use ten minutes later
you arrive at the hospital parking in
your spot you get out and walk directly
to the payphone remembering the number
you dial it after two rings you hear a
male voice answer yeah la got taken down
in Richmond Heights finish the deal you
stay more meekly than you meant to the
voice doesn't respond the phone hangs up
dead you hang up well that went well you
think going into the hospital you step
into an elevator and take it to the
fourth floor considering various various
excuses along the way there's no there's
one option it's just as inside the
elevator doors open up and you stand in
a small ant ant room auntie Ramona say
that a locked door on either side of the
behavior of medicine inpatient unit the
walls have been freshly painted painted
dark green and the sport at high foot
high strip of patterned wallpaper to the
top the hospital executives thought a
quick makeover of the lobby would
otherwise cover up the disgusting state
state of the unit and improve visitor
relations getting your master key you
ignore the buzzer and the joining sign
which reads push button in state
business unlock the east door and you
enter the unit you enter the psych ward
the inside of the unit is very different
from the touched up pant room everything
is that drab gray and the drywall is
cracked in places
most of the unit is geriatric patients
and wheelchairs many of them are total
care that the fact means this fact means
they shouldn't piss themselves and can't
move much less walk and due to dementia
they often try to stand up this place is
held coincidentally it's shaped like a
big H 15 Plus old demented people try to
stand up ripping out their catheters
feeding tubes falling and smashing on
their faces on the floor with six total
staff on a good day and only three
covering the area you're now looking at
it's ridiculous for the clinical
director to expect safety a couple of
years ago you worked here as an RN and
these factors were the major reason you
so quickly got your master's degree no
longer would you be one of those
foreigners so struggling to keep their
licenses and health their backs from all
the lifting now you talk to the patients
right orders and leave no more lifting
no more cleaning fish feces no more a
tower for patients yelling in your face
well nearly the you nearly scream that's
right every time you enter the unit yeah
you can go up to the nursing station or
enter the bathroom hold on there's a map
and it's shaped like an H yes this is
the unit above and below the center of
the H it says elevators the red dot is
where you enter patient room and then
there's patient rooms on both sides of
the age and the middle says nursing
station and we're up at the top right
and it says legend the red dot is where
you entered the unit the black box is
the staff bathroom so those are the two
places we could go right next
hmm I don't know nursing station yeah
you walk up to the nursing nursing
station Devon the unit security sees you
immediately secretary sorry
um sees you immediately and says hi dr.
Singh I don't have my PhD yet and even
if I did I know you don't want me I know
I you know I want you to call me Dominic
you respond affectionately Devon is your
first name only several hard workers in
the unit and you have a positive
professional relationship she refuses to
call you by your first name citing
respect as their reason I've got your
roster here your rosters a list of
patients that you need to see and
possibly write orders on Devon hasn't
mentioned anything yet about you being
late no doctors are in sight dr.
Gulliver and yet you casually ask Devon
winks at you conspiratorial II nope
no one knows you were late dr. st. she
glances at the whole clock damn you are
late everything okay her sense of
genuine concern you sense her genuine
concern yes Devon everything's okay had
a little car trouble okay well she's a
roster she starts to walk away her you
start to walk away and she calls after
you dr. st. your cell phone you left it
here yesterday afternoon so that's what
that thing was thank you I was running
right where I'd left that not being a
physician has its privileges you don't
have to be on call so it's not as
strange not strange you forget your
phone nonetheless you're glad to have it
back so you can take the cell phone so
now in our inventory we have our
character sheet a speeding ticket and a
cell phone looking at your roster hi
Dern good look Nina Ross sir you have
three patients to see today dr. Zola
must have discharged the other two first
there's Julie a 37 year old female with
bipolar disorder she was admitted after
she tried to over to overdose on 15
tylenol but then decided she wanted I
went to the emergency department she's
very depressed and cries frequently
since her admission she's gained 15
pounds next was Antonio 25 year old male
with antisocial personality disorder he
was admitted when he went to the
emergency department and stated he would
kill himself he has a history of crack
cocaine abuses homeless and very
manipulative and drug seeking despite
his charming demeanor he is prone to
outbursts and physical violence most
likely Antonio lied about wanting to
kill himself
get free room and board this statement
is not pious it's commonly called
malingering in the psych profession
finally there's April a 51 year old
female with psychosis not otherwise
specified Nos
she was admitted after a cop saw her in
the middle of a busy street holding up a
Bible over a head yelling passages from
revelations
April is hyper religious and bizarre and
often places the hall reading script
paces the hall reading scripture aloud
and then lapse into absolute silence for
hours okay you can talk to Julie Antonio
April and then you're finished with your
rest so we're probably gonna end up
talking all of them let's just start all
right we talked to Julie you find Julie
in her room she's sitting in her bed
weeping you knock on the front door and
say hello she slowly looks up blotting
the tears from her eyes are you here to
see me she asked Olli I sure AM let's go
into the group room and talk you realize
it'll be therapeutic to get her out of
this room where she has no doubt
sequestered herself you unlock the the
group room door and let Julie Ann and
Tony here come striding in and you to
you and Stan's inappropriately close
what's up doc you gonna write me some
percocet might actually hurt me he says
affably smiling smiling confidently I'm
with another patient Antonio he smiles
his smile fades ever so subtly but
you're gonna write me that percocet his
eyes were on two he moves a step closer
you're in my space again we talked about
this last time remember I'll speak with
you later
Antonio backs up starts smiling again
one fist is clenched you wait till you
move safely away before you turn your
back and enter the group room don't
forget about that percocet you hear a
call from the hallway you sit down with
Julie you can hear what she has to say
sitting down you say things don't look
like they're going so well she leave
sniffles and replies no you wait but she
doesn't know about two months ago your
office Julie was bouncing off the walls
smiling joking laughing her current
depression is more part of her bipolar
disorder than any understandable
stimulus such as getting divorced or
losing one's job I'm getting fat she
finally continues look at me I've gained
like 20 pounds you're currently treating
her with several drugs most notably
xanax and depakote addressing these
factors you reply we don't want to
change anything in this crucial point or
let's rethink your medicines or I'll
think about concerns and get back to you
I'll think and get back to you for sure
yeah
all right you can go back to your rounds
Julie I'm Julie I understand your
concerns but I'm not sure we're going to
what we're going to do about them let me
think about and get back to you she
sniffles nods and gets up to leave I'll
see you tomorrow now we can talk her
then Tony oh okay it's not too hard to
find Antonio he's been following you
around ever since you were out on the
unit he's hovering over you dressed and
dirty he just wants parkas that oh yes
his fists clenched as you approach the D
room he stands up from the card game he
was playing in strides toward you sup
doc my turn everyone insists on calling
you doctor doctor because you write
prescriptions and you were tired of
correcting them your turn let's go to
the staff lounge to talk
it looks exactly like the day room with
glass doors sink tables and chairs but
it's in plain sight of the nursing
station staff lounge
I thought you take everybody the group
room hee hee questions you know if your
being alone with this little punk in the
group room but such an action would be
unwise considering his violent
tendencies motioning him to the staff
lounge you ignore the comment see what
Antonia has to say ok sitting down with
Antonia you consult your notes this
patient has been here for three days and
you don't have him on any medications
despite having stated to an emergency
department nurse that he would kill
himself he evidences no signs or
symptoms of depression rather he has a
normal he has normal sleeping patterns
play cards all day orders extra food on
this tray and wanders the unit though
his about his staff demanding some
doctors fake fix his ingrown toenail and
give him pain medicine Port Antonio
stares at you expectantly so Antonio you
feeling suicidal oh yeah I want to kill
myself
what sort of things make you want to
kill yourself [ __ ] doc everything I just
want to kill myself
Antonio looks annoyed and leans towards
you across the table have you formulated
a plan to kill yourself plan what do you
mean plan he looks confused how would
you kill yourself ignoring your question
entirely he says you're the best doc
here I'm starting to feel better but I
need to look at my toe I need some pain
medicine he tears off his shoe and puts
his dirty foot on the table his great
toes nail obviously ingrown it's brown
and crusty hmm gross this isn't a
medical unit Antonio you're here because
you're a danger to yourself as you told
me Antonio Antonio seeing that his
polite words are getting him nowhere he
narrows his eyes [ __ ] I need
some goddamn pain meds this thing hurts
alright I'll write you some Tylenol
extra strength or I can transfer you to
medical you start to get up your
assessment finished percocet doc I need
percocet Tylenol I ain't gonna do [ __ ]
he screams he nearly screams holding his
gaze you say evenly you won't be getting
any percocet here Antonio he stares back
with obvious rage gets up slams the
table with his palms leaves the room you
shake your head and consider discharging
him jotting down a few notes and get
back to your rounds he dropped something
on the floor or you go back to your
rounds oh he dropped something on the
floor
well in his anger something dropped from
Antonia Wow happening it more carefully
you cease to steal the condom you
certainly can't just leave it lying on
the floor you pick it up either throw it
away or keep it
maybe it will prove of some use to you
we picked up a condom y'all Oh all right
let's go talk to April April April is
pacing up and down the hall Bible in her
hand
her head hangs low her Brown curls of
sweeping hair hover her hair sweeping
her shoulder with each step she's very
tall for her sex but not certainly so
like the volleyball player you once had
an award approaching her you say her
name wants April she pauses in her
meditation and looks up no recognition
apparent in her eyes it's Dominic she
continues to look at you her eyes Dolan
mouth slack as though she's sedated
walking back to the nurse's station she
you ask a nurse how April's been today
she was screaming for hours before you
got here running up and down the halls
we gave her some ativan Iams so April's
sedated for a necessary factor obviously
that's why you prescribed it to her to
be used as needed you walk up to April
who's still standing over there watching
you April let's go to the group room and
talk okay she responds April stands next
to the chair obviously unwilling to sit
down you sit hoping she will follow your
lead how are you April about 30 seconds
later she says fine she sits down are
you hearing voices she says yes I hear
God's voice she grips her Bible firmly
in her hand what does this voice tell
you he tells me that you're all sinners
all of you the devil works in ways we
cannot imagine April thrusts the Bible
at you in accusation how's your husband
you shift the subject knowing that this
woman was a reliable first-grade teacher
only two weeks ago apparently paying no
attention she raises her voice and yells
sinners all of you April then begins to
silent pray silently pray although her
thin lips move with each words she then
lapses into a stupor estate it ignores
you you're not going to get anything out
of her at this point the blood tests are
fine no drug or alcohol abuse no
psychological trauma you can determine
from speaking with the husband the best
thing is to hope that she snaps out of
whatever psychosis she's in out of in
until whenever she becomes Restless or
agitated than she was now Thank You
April I'll see you tomorrow she stands
up without answering leaves the room you
jot down notes and continue with your
browse you're finished with your rounds
finnish-speaking all three patients you
head back to the nursing station and
write your orders intuition tells you
something bad is about to happen but you
only wanna know a second to react do you
react in time as our only choice too
slow to react Oh a fist hits you from
the side your drawers crush sideways
from the floor to put to your side
shaking off you quickly turn and observe
your attacker Antonio his blindside you
said [ __ ] you ain't even a
doctor he swings another right towards
your face and nurses are rushing at him
from all sides but you and instantly
realize that if you don't take action
now this punch will definitely connect
possibly doing serious damage you've
lost five endurance points and allow the
punch to connect try to dodge the punch
or retaliate
it says retaliate after all it is in
legal defense of your person I say try
to dodge it and I don't think you should
punch a patient we dodged the punch
rather than let his punch connector
retaliate you instinctively dodge you
fluidly moved to the side and his punch
misses Oh Antonio falls forward with his
missed blow but you step away from step
away instead of striking him in the
throat like you badly want to a second
later nurses tackle and Tony from all
sides and pin it down you calmly order
Haldol 10 milligram I am stat probably a
sedation
when while Antonio rods in squirms about
the floor screaming curse words laced
with rape racial epithets Evan goes to
the Med room and prepares the drug while
you while you yearn to retaliate you
silently praise yourself for remaining
calm and handling the situation as an
adult yes you're 32 but it's difficult
to think of yourself as an adult when
you're still so filled with vices and
violent temperament
oh sorry minutes later Evan swabs
Antonio's arm yeah
then injects the Halal into his left
shoulder I'm still cursing and trying to
kick you he's dragged towards seclusion
ah
dusting off your Jackie proceed to your
orders all in a day's work Beach you're
not even a doctor you finish writing
your orders from their charts doing what
you told your patients you would think
of Antonio from your assessment you
decide if he's malingering or and not
suicided suicidal at all however due to
federal law if you were to discharge him
and he were to kill himself you could be
held liable hopefully he'll become angry
when he doesn't get any percocet our
medical attention for his toe and demand
to leave against medical advice AMA then
you'd be free and clear you'd have to
speak with doctors Ayla about this but
be sure you put your sure she'll trust
your judgment finished with your duties
for the day you take a look at the clock
it's nearly 5:00 o'clock damn it's late
usually you finish a little time a
little afternoon this but today has been
a unique experience to put him oddly the
Sun is very low in the sky and the
shadows of Twilight are upon you
you go outside the hospital once you
were safely out of view of the
hospital's entrance you light a
cigarette to take a long drag you unlock
your car get in and consider your
options drive back to your apartment
that's all it's getting dark outside
your house is illuminated by an orange
glow your day's adventures well together
in your head squirming like the lost
rodents and a status maze paranoia grips
you because you were last encounter with
the cops at least it didn't end with you
murdering the pigs not that the thought
didn't cross your mind but that but that
was not a past you wanted to revisit
your thankfully you managed to avoid you
know your natural urge to kill the
worthless crackhead that was Antonio
crushing his trachea whatever moved what
one more of flesh from one more waste of
flesh from the world that certainly
destroyed your career you randomly
wander wonder how lamonta is doing it a
few remembers that you didn't rat at
least you called his contact one less
person to worry about having out for you
you go to unlock your door to your
apartment but curiously it's not only is
it unlocked but it's slightly ajar the
door is ajar
oh my god you cautiously enter you feel
a sense of foreboding everything looks
the way you left it but a gnawing
sensation tells your brain in your brain
tells you to be careful straining your
ears is futile you hear nothing no one
is in the family room alert you creep
room to room but nothing but no appears
to be within however your door to your
office is closed you don't remember
closing it you throw up in the door
stubborn as a mule born with neurologic
defect you throw up in the door howling
like a bloodthirsty pirate expecting the
worst it takes a minute to register what
you see Leon your friend from New York
City is sitting at your computer typing
away he seems unconcerned at you hurling
open the door and screaming like a
maniac your mouth hangs open as he
processed the information how you
stammer hey dude don't look so surprised
he says calmly the cigarette he's
holding in his right hand has smoldered
down a really long - notice this
noticing this he stubs it out I left you
like a million messages I didn't know
you were coming you begin and when the
hell did you get here you asked and what
Stacy here you continue hopefully and
how the [ __ ] did you get in my apartment
you finish relax man like I said I told
you to call me back and you didn't so
here I am no I didn't see your girl
amuse you grant holy [ __ ] you should see
the day I've been having I almost killed
your ass killed me Leon chuckles I heard
you coming since you opened the door man
don't forget Who I am and what we did
together he arches his eyebrow
accusingly but you make no but you sense
no malice this is one of your best
friends after all and yes he helped you
out in a really tight spot but I never
asked anything in return you smiled
broadly well it's good to see you though
I don't know why you're here in a minute
anything strange go down the lobby
he says in a minute anything straight to
go down the lobby you tell Leon
everything well what the who's that guy
you and Leon sit down on your couch and
you recount the date details of your day
leaving out nothing during the story his
expression barely changes though he
lasts with points at points at the end
he lights up another cigarette thinking
despite self being self sufficient you
will welcome any advice you might give
you finally he looks down on you and
says you stupid [ __ ] we got a lot to
talk about oh yeah yeah I found your
note on the door from your girl said you
left your cell at the hospital that that
was helpful
you think he assesses your reaction says
fine you want some Confucius like advice
considering your past choices he tells
you least you [ __ ] with the cops we
got a lot to talk about you ready you
had you think over what Nia Leon has
said what do we have to talk about
what's going on he suddenly looks dead
serious we'll talk about it but not here
any good bars in the tornado pit of town
the loop has some decent ones you answer
which ones you explain the best bars
Cicero's and you giving directions you
had for the loop-the-loop home of
various bars and grills
as well as fine restaurants a tattoo
parlor and three shops lined Del Mar the
main thoroughfare you pull into a
parking lot in front of Cicero's and
it's a pizza joint and beer joint as you
step out of the car a man with a white
grizzled beard and tattered dirty
clothes approaches you he holds out his
hand smiles missing two of his otherwise
darkly stained teeth
um sir anything for an old vet don't
give him anything as your only option
patting your pockets you say sorry I
don't have anything for you you move on
head inside Cicero's it's crowded in
here the beautiful decor and
upper-middle-class atmosphere in the
front is offset by the speedy by the
seedy pool table and jukebox to your
left at the far rear of your restaurant
where a filthy carpet replaces the white
tie with its tasteful black squares
waitress is carrying bottles of food
weave in and out of the customers
sitting at tables and white cloth some
laughing so I'm getting ready to order
various plants hanging from the ceiling
Hey Jude is playing softly in the
background only two tables are open a
booth in the very back can you have a
pool table and some bikers and a table
right in front of you you take the table
to the left or the back you sit at the
table to your left
Leon walks over from the bar where he
was waiting for you and sits down almost
immediately a waitress approaches and
takes your drink orders needing to drink
needing to keep your mind sharp both of
you order a coke instead of alcohol the
waitress walks off and Leon leans
towards you Dom we've been friends for a
long time I loved you in the past and
never asked for anything in return now I
need your help he stares at you
measuring your reaction
you've rarely seen him so serious of
course man but your voice mail sounded
pretty bad just tell me what's going on
okay listen you know my ties with the
Russian mob which is how I helped you
get rid of those he looked around to
make sure no one was listening corpses
there's a guy named Serge I'm not
connected that well or I'd have no
problem luckily either as he the
difficulty is that the mob won't take
sides it's not worth their time they'll
let us fight it out and deal with the
result
Leon lights a cigarette and blows a ring
of smoke into the air stopped assembling
what sort of problem are you having with
this guy you asked Leon liens even
closer the problem [ __ ] that we we both
deal
and things that fell off trucks Leon
makes little quotation marks with his
fingers and you almost laugh obviously
stolen merchandise we have to cut the
mob a percentage of course to work in
their neighborhood Serge is getting
pretty big for his [ __ ] britches and
hit one of my shipments killed one of my
guys took the stuff I don't take care of
him I'm dead you pause taking in
everything he said I see the problem in
but don't you have people to take care
of this
Leon blows out another cloud of smoke
yeah dick bag I have people but I think
Serge is buying them off I don't trust
those [ __ ] they'd kill their own
members for enough money and right now
Serge has more money than me
I've got ray and I've got you only once
I trust only ones who wouldn't turn me
in for money
old school [ __ ] Oh old school he coughs
and looks around and yells where's my
[ __ ] coke so what role would I play
the waitress comes up glares at Leon and
puts both cokes down then walks away
without bothering to take your food
order neither of you is looked up at the
menu anyway you me ray we arm ourselves
and bust into surges [ __ ] of an
apartment and kill them all how many
five six less than ten five six less
than ten how about twenty how many Leon
listen men yeah yeah yeah there's more
but there won't be there and besides we
kill Serge and they just get merged
mercenaries for hire not my problem we
hit them at night without too many guys
and we'll be fine
you owe me Dom you [ __ ] owe me will
you help me or not our choices are of
course I'll help you or I can't I'm out
of that life now and I'm not going back
I say [ __ ] it
and do it ya already helped us and he
can always expose us bash he did loyalty
all right I'll do it you've agreed to
help Leon out of loyalty you don't need
to be told again how much he helped you
how much your new life depended on his
aid to getting rid of those bodies
telling him you're out of that life
would be a slap in his face
you just hope he doesn't knock you into
oblivion of psychosis time will tell
that's what I'm talking about [ __ ] oh he
looks around let's get the hell out of
here I've got plane tickets not even
bothering to order you throw down some
money for the sodas and go with Leon our
only choice says go to the airport the
upper level of Lambert is barren it's
late enough that no one is waiting in
line to check bags or buy tickets as you
walk towards the escalators Leon
produces two first-class one-way tickets
he laughs at your expression what I know
you'd come with me and I don't fly coach
I'll get you another ticket when we
finish with Serge business must be going
well
damn you answer it will be a lot better
once we get to take once we take Serge
out but yeah yeah it's going well
our flights at 9:00 p.m. gate 23 let's
go together you walk towards security
and stand in line it's currently 7:45
p.m. with the advent of terrorism people
are taking shoes off and throwing away
bottles of lotion hopefully you don't
have anything that will call notice to
your presence when your turn comes you
walk through the metal detector our only
choice says nothing beeps any proceed
through security
finally through security you and Leon
head to gate 23 it's now 8:20 p.m. the
drab gray carpet does nothing to improve
your increasingly poor mood worried you
feel your hands start to tremble
a pale sheen of sweat covers your
forehead and you wipe it away with the
back of your hand when you arrive at the
gate they're already boarding the plane
Leon says ah yeah that's lucky he
glances over at you you all right [ __ ]
oh you look kind of pale smiling weakly
you reply sure I just don't like the fly
while I didn't used to like to fly
thought I got over that I need to sit
down a minute we can't sit down they're
boarding no way we're missing this
flight come on let's go our only choice
says he's right you need to board the
plane now
you feel almost unable to continue
irrational fear grips your mind notions
of me notions of nitrous on the plane me
Beach notions of malfunctioning engines
and 50-ton stones dropping 30,000 feet
passengers screaming at the long descent
before the final rest two minutes of
absolute horror Dom [ __ ] man I've been
calling your name for like a minute snap
out of it have a drink or something our
only choice says take your seat no I'm
gonna jump it for a few you and Leon
sink into the blush leather seats and
breathe a sigh of relief
the captain announces that the skies are
clear you'll be taking off without a
delay a flight attendant immediately
approaches with a plastic smile and
offers you both a cocktail I'll take a
gin and tonic Leon says your orders are
orders Scotch rocks or pull out your
wink bottle that you had ordered through
wink calm oh my god Julian because
Dominic had some forethought forethought
to this trip and he knew that if he had
gotten his winged subscription he would
have got me why delivered to his house
and he could have had it on a plane now
I will not say that planes will allow
you to bring full bottles of wine from
wink but you will wish that you could
bring your wink bottles onto the plane
what week dot try winked calm /nn Julian
guys try wings on console agenda
Angeline sorry or click the link in the
description it's much easier but yeah
the the URL is tri wink T ry winc comm
slash Jenna and Julian for $20 off
because there's no membership fees you
skip any month cancel any time and
shipping is complimentary ok
it is an awesome service basically where
wine experts take a flavor profile you
fill out and select wine they're experts
they know what they're doing they select
one that they know you'll like and they
send it to your house all you have to do
is fill out the links special palate
profile quiz they send wine directly to
your door and if you don't like a bottle
they send to you they'll replace it with
the bottle you'll love no questions
asked I mean how do you get a better
deal there check it out guys click link
them in the description you will
definitely like it also guys I never get
excited about underwear it lets them
talk about me and ease because me and
he's the only underwear I wear and I
think you should check it out if you
have not they're fun comfy undies that
feel as good as they look they have
nudists
of really really cool patterns and
prints every single month once you put
on a parrot you get it you just get it
because it's better than any underwear
you want mmm
trust I also love not having to go to
the store a man descends underwear right
to your door okay and a beautiful little
package with a new design it's so cool
but if designs are for you they have
plain prints they have all sorts of
different types of underwear they even
have bra let's and socks now and if
you're not sure well mandis can nudge in
the right direction okay because you get
twenty four twenty percent off for first
pair of manatees free shipping and
satisfaction guarantee when you go to me
undies dot-com slash Jenna Julianne or
click link in the description guys you
will not be sorry you just won't thank
you sponsor it's both longtime sponsors
and supplier Terrance that they've had
can mm-hmm okay
you order a scotch rocks I think we
should order yeah we should order a
drink ah the calming effects of alcohol
dangerous to every organ in the body
it's so effective effective on the
limbic system you feel instantly relaxed
this liquid goes down your throat and
warms your belly brings a pleasant flush
to your cheeks you sit back and the
plush seats and enjoy the flight at some
point you doze off an hour waking at JFK
Airport by Leon shaking you you get up
and leave the plane you're as you're in
first class you two are the first of the
first of the plane having no luggage you
head immediately to the exit outside you
breathe in the incomparable smells of
New York pollution mixed with the sense
of fresh bagels from every corner vendor
permeate the air people stride and even
run past around you jostling you
slightly with their movements eat that's
very accurate each has a place that they
have to go and need to go now
fixed faces and featureless eyes focused
on the destination the intensity and
purpose of New Yorkers have always
pleased and comforted you how very
different from the slow easy pace of
affable familiar of Midwestern yet a
welcome change particularly since you
enjoy an anonymity here that is present
nowhere else
Leon hails a cab and you both get it
we're going to Brooklyn 15th Avenue he
tells the cab you stare out the window
and hope Stacey is okay sleeping on the
plane has restored your endurance to its
maximum oh yeah yeah our endurance back
up there Julian's apartment the cab
pulls up of the curb
Leon pays the driver and walks ahead of
you fishing for his key in his left
pocket he his height rivals yours but
his frame is a bit lankier striding
towards the door his right hand
scratches the jet black stubble the top
of his head as he is a bit ahead of you
and has just entered the lobby Leon
doesn't notice you the dwarf who
accosted you perhaps four feet tall
about five feet wide the creature is
absolutely filthy his face line and
weathered a huge bushy red beard covers
his face and you too can own and you can
only see two bright spots where his eyes
peer out of as you at you from under an
equally thick bushy eyebrows to act two
axes are tethered to his belt one on
each side of his thick waist he looked
like he doesn't belong in this world
we got no time boy my name be Corrigan I
know who you be you got the symbols
given to me and me king will be pleased
I got something for you he helps a small
piece of stone in his calloused hands
and eyeing you meaningfully you have one
option it's to ignore the dwarf and
enter Leon's room what the [ __ ] that's
not a good term is it yeah that's I
think that's derogatory well it also
sounds like he's having a hallucination
maybe there are at least three computers
in this room all functional and humming
quietly Leon falls into his high-back
leather swivel chair and flips out his
phone pushing a speed dial number hey
what's up dick back yeah yeah come here
we're doing it tonight yeah tonight
slight pause okay I see you soon Leon
hangs up glancing at the wall clock you
see it's 1:05 a.m. the flight was two
and a half hours you lost an hour going
with the East Coast not to mention
getting all the way to Brooklyn from JFK
you sit on leaves been waiting for Ray
all three of the three of you were
inseparable until you and Leon both
descended into hardcore drug abuse and
distribution at which point Ray wisely
JumpShip however he has never ceased to
be a good friend you would trust him
with your life and tonight apparently
Rochelle Leon cell phone rings to learn
marae's arrival Leon Baz Luhrmann
oh [ __ ] dude it's going down ray walks
into Leon's room as though he's been in
the apartment 100 times before and in
fact he has he and Leon grew up together
Leon in this very house the only
difference is the arrangements as Leon
now pays the rent and buys the
necessities raised perhaps five nine
hundred ninety pounds not obese but
rather stocky and solid looking he's an
Italian Hispanic mixed with black hair
fair skin and a strong jaw raised the
most polite of all of you even with an
even temperament slow to lose control
and yet a terror to behold when he has
been roused to anger you hug him roughly
in Pat his cheek good to see you again
man you too he replies so we're really
gonna do it Leon nods really gonna do it
Leon gods raise motivation are probably
loyalty as he would not normally become
a match than anything this dangerous and
illegal Leon leaves the room momentarily
and that that moment ray gives you a
peculiar look as though he wants to tell
you something but can't the moment is
gone and Leon returns to the room okay
my mom's asleep he pulls an old army
chest out of his bed
I'm from under his bed unlocks it and
throws it open with some relish choose
one and then we'll decide on a plan
three weapons are thrown haphazardly at
the bottom whoa a Mossberg 500 persuader
shotgun looks like a double pump no it
looks like a pump shotgun um a heckler
and cost mp5 it's like an SMG or a dual
beretta 92fs pistols let me take the SMG
yeah the ropey
okay when you've made your choice to use
the weapon okay use it
but think you have to use it in your
inventory use item
you reach for the heckler mp5 but Leon
knocks your hand away either of the
other ones I love the H&K [ __ ] Oh Leon
glares at you as though daring you to
reach her it again he's not worth the
trouble so you examine your other
options
so you have to take the handguns or the
shotgun what do you want let's take it
use it you you have the Mossberg 500
shotgun and smile at it's comforting way
and famed reliability Leon hands you a
case of shells which you meth Adak Lee
insert into the weapon finally pumping
it wants to load the first shell ray
grabs the dual Berettas in Leon picks up
the mp5 go over the plan or change your
mind and choose the different weapon
let's go over the point let's go over
we're a weapon master we're gonna be
fine wait we gotta kill somebody this is
[ __ ] up but we're gonna be fine by the
way this is not a normal pocket if this
is the first time you're watching our
podcast is not a normal popular side I
mean I honestly didn't know that this
would be this long but I am you might
not be able to finish it yeah there's a
chance I mean I don't know cuz I don't
have no idea when the end is yeah so but
like because I looked up like some
reviews on it and none of them were like
this this is like a five-hour thing so I
just assumed that it would be why don't
we see where it goes in the next couple
minutes and if we have to go part two on
another podcast we'll do that mmm I'm
into it though I think it's yeah that's
fun having chosen your weapons Leon
array gather around the bed as Leon
unfolds a large piece of paper okay I've
never been a surges house but I have
associates who have one of them was
willing well-paid to draw me up a
blueprint of the property I'm thinking
all three of us should kick in the front
door and start killing they're not
expecting anything and there won't be
more or five of them more than five of
them including Serge I thought you said
there could be five six no more than ten
Leon you asked Ray looks at lea for
confirmation of this possibility now
fuchal it'll be more than five and we'll
have the element of surprise the three
of us open fire and everybody dies array
looks a bit skeptical but we'll follow
your lead
what if I run back would not be better
you ask yeah I would but Serge has got a
pit bull he sleeps out back somewhere
he's not sure he's not a trained attack
dog or anything but I have heard he's
huge and he doesn't like anybody but
search puppy dog what about the fence
you poke your finger at the diagram how
we gonna get past that do you don't even
know why he drew that it's just a
regular fence we can drop jump it Leon
roses I've lies Leon rolls his eyes
what'll it be then Oh we'll take the
blueprint if you want it studying the
map you decide that all three of you
will kick in the front door it up and
fire all three of you will creep down
the alleyway and sneak in back two of
you will sneak around back and one of
you will go straight to the front
if you wish to use your weapon master
trade click here if you would wish to
use your six cents trade quick you oh I
definitely want to use one of our senses
let's use the weapon master okay or I
mean I don't know six cents might allow
us to figure out the best way to get
into the house because I don't think
that splitting up would be a good choice
no I think you say together yeah but I
wonder what weapon master isn't that
just like our our trait like why would
we use that yeah
let's use six cents
I don't know I don't know either well
let's take the blueprint okay
what's you success okay you're six you
sense that splitting up oh it's me wrong
but only if you could somehow take care
of the pit bull that looks around back
unfortunately your sixth sense tell you
nothing more than this thinking about
how to stop a pit bull you consider
drugs depressants to be more exact
quiet ineffective oh no we bout to drug
the dog go back terrible person yeah go
back and maybe do this only on our
thoughts and ask him if he has anything
of you oh yeah totally on your thoughts
alright we tell her Leon you have a
needle no [ __ ] oh I stop that [ __ ] a
long time ago he glances at ray and you
give and you man this is important I
know you're still using I can tell by
your eyes give me a [ __ ] syringe and
some heroin Leon sighs and puts a pull
the clean needle in a small packet out
of the toolbox next to his computer fine
here ray starts getting angry but you
quiet him this is too important we can
use this thing on the dog Oh God
shooting him would be loud and I want a
killer dog anyway you dumped a bit of
hair I want to kill a dog who wants to
kill a person
hmm what the hell is it bad people this
is bad all right so you think that you
you're Six Senses splitting up into B
vest so yeah we will wait I want to use
our weapon master trade too because now
we're back at this screen okay let's do
that
okay unfortunately your endurance is not
high enough to effectively use your
weapon master trade wha damn okay all
three of you will kick in the front door
and up and fired now all three of you
will creep or other Holly way of
sneaking back two of you so we'll do two
of you sneak around back one in the
front
yep that's our only choice split up two
of us should sneak around back another
goes in the in the front door best
combination of stealth and assault Ray
shrugs but looks a bit vex Leon says I
don't know if [ __ ] oh we should probably
stick together I'm telling you man
splitting up is the best idea
Leon arremato finally ray speaks up I
don't know Dom I think we should stick
together it's not like I wanna bust into
someone's house and kill people with
weapons if we're gonna do this we need
to do it together
so you have to go back and make a new
plan okay it's your only option
I guess you just busted in the front
door no we're gonna creep down the
alleyway and see you in the back because
that dog is yeah let's go in the back I
don't think surprise will be enough we
go through the front rain odds but Leon
says whatever [ __ ] just cuz ray thinks
is a good idea
I do too I'll do it he sighs
dramatically the three of you creep from
Leon's room careful not to wake his
mother downstairs Leon leads you to a
beat-up Volvo it's color is dull white
do the dirt and grime covering the
ancient paint job the three of you get
in Leon at the wheel and drive to search
his house pulling up to the curb Leon
cuts the engine about two blocks away
okay we jumped the fence creep around
the back porch and kick in the door kill
anybody else you see and watch out for
the pit bull you and Ray nod your palms
feel sweaty and your anxiety is rising
but no amount of ativan would help at
this point
well someone but you don't you need to
be as sharp as possible the outskirts of
surges property the three of you climb
up and jump down cringing as the fence
makes a small amount of noise you sprint
down the gravel path towards Search's
house even from here you can hear
explosions coming from inside the house
and loud yelling despite any absence of
light there was a house to the left of
surges in some sort of store to the
right but they sit quiet and motionless
without any lights of any kind crouched
you can all move even closer to the
house you creep down the alleyway to the
back porch the alleyway is quiet and
very very dark there are no streetlights
around and you strain your eyes to make
your way to the backyard in less than a
minute the three of you come out of the
alley and look around the backyard
backyard is quiet the porch light cast a
long shadow over the yard and you can
barely make out a wooden doghouse
directly to your left about ten feet
from the back porch you aren't sure but
you think you see a dog lying with its
nose out the front of the doghouse
probably asleep as he certainly would
have started barking if he had detected
you afraid to speak you motion towards
the dog but ran Leon's show they see it
two eyes widening with recognition and a
small amount of their heads with its
propping cute propping acuity to the
porch that's such an unnecessary word
when did being close to the porch you
doubt you could sneak sneak up on the
porch without awaking to the gut the dog
besides you can't tell who's inside the
back of the house from this distance and
who might be looking out better option
would be to creep up and somehow put the
dog out of commission but only if you
quietly the loud sounds are still coming
from the house you change your mind and
go around the front you motion for Leon
and Ray to wait and then carefully sneak
up to the pitbull or you try to sneak up
to the porch anyway we should sneak up
to the pitfall that was our plan hmmm
ever so quietly you approach the pitbull
your eyes never leaving its closed once
as you approach it snorts and adjusts
itself the creature is obviously not
very vigilant but you cringe at these
movements now within an arm reach of the
dog you consider your option maybe this
wasn't such an idea good idea creep back
to Leon ray can we use the syringe use
item we use item fairly slowly you pull
the syringe out of your pocket and uncap
that is an uncapped so the needle is
exposed utterly you're focused on your
task you bend it in closer to the pit
you bend in closer to the pit when
you're close enough to smell his breath
you simultaneously grab his collar and
Ram the needle into his neck depressing
as well as quickly as possible the dog
Oh flip flick open in instinctively
wrenches away from you you and yelps
quietly pulling towards the causing and
causing you to sprawl on top of him he
tries to shrug you off but quickly goes
limp you hurry often and back up but
he's not moving the needle is still
protruding from his neck very carefully
you examine the dog he's still breathing
in his eyes are still open he'll be all
right though you doubt he'll be barking
for another couple of hours satisfied
that's still [ __ ] up yeah satisfied
that you were both successful and you
didn't permantly damaged the dog you
moved to Leon and Ray I can't believe
that [ __ ] worked alright let's get on
the porch and kill these [ __ ] back
gorgeous creeping on the back porch you
you peek through the screen door
straining down to the hallway straining
to see down the hallway in the living
room on the right way directly behind
you out of view of the door there
kneeling quietly in there silence is
broken homie by Leon taking the safety
off the mp5 doing it due to the ruckus
within you can see the gigantic
television the living room but nothing
else the television blares the sounds of
gunshots and violence and people are
cheering and cursing at each other
good-natured inside the room they play
in pub G probably you whisper the
solution Oh Leon ray situation if you
wish to use your weapon master trade
click here let's try that I don't think
burns wait yeah
yeah we don't yeah let's go rushing down
the hall and open fire we have the
element of surprise we might have the
element of surprise bullets creepin
creepin what are you gonna do run in
there with your claw peak lob feat you
it's not a good idea you mean you've
come this far creepy why would ya expose
yourself you whisper to Leon and Ray
that you should all sneak in and then
creep from the master bath to the master
bedroom making sure no one in the
kitchen on is in a kitchen on its way if
all your rooms are clear you you can
rush the living room you sneak in
creeping down the hallway peeking into
the kitchen bathroom you see no one
entering the living room you see that
the Russians have been completely taken
off guard
without hesitation you fired the
Mossberg into one of the restrooms a
surprise look in his eyes he lays back
on the couch thank God
he lays against the back of the couch
and lets out a tremendous silence it's
unmoving the other three have already
tossed their controllers and picked up
ak-47 assault rifle neon unleashes with
the mp5 spreading the room he manages to
riddle
two of the men with bullets but not
before one is fired at you his bullets
tearing into the wallpaper and ending
your left shoulder Oh
the remaining Russian tries to run for
the back of the room but Ray fires his
Baretta's into the but his back blowing
his body forward and lay unmoving on the
tiled hallway smiling Leon moves over to
his corpse and in the hallways spits on
it there you go search you [ __ ] then a
strange thing happens Leon turns and
open fires on ray who has already
lowered his weapon Ray's body twitches
spasmodically with the bullets all
stories I got pop administering a moment
later he collapses his belly so
mutilated that his intestines whose onto
the floor like questing worms confusion
sets in what is going on Leon points his
weapon at you drop it [ __ ] oh you
consider he screams louder drop it or
I'll kill you no I swear to God drop
your weapon
now kick it towards me Leon angrily you
kick Leon says angrily you kick the
weapon towards him isn't is this how you
repay a friend you ask better lately on
sighs I didn't want it to be this way
you know he pauses you know why rain
came along on this thing his eyes with
considered consideration no you reply
sullenly he came along because he didn't
want to tell you something because he
wanted to tell you something [ __ ] back
he wanted to tell you that the cops had
been asking some questions lately he was
our friend and I stupidly told him what
we did all those years ago he didn't say
anything but he knew oh he knew knew
what knew that only you and he could
finger me
get me put away Leon arches his eyebrows
and looks at you meaningfully so you
[ __ ] killed him you yell spittle fly
from your lips he couldn't be trusted
and neither can i after after I said I'd
help you you [ __ ] Leon laughs hey I
trust both of you to a certain extent
and I needed you I couldn't have taken
surges gettin by myself but with both of
you and Serge dead I don't have to worry
about a thing he raises the mp5 to the
level of your chest sorry [ __ ] Leon
pulls the trigger nothing happens you
realize that gun is jammed the guns
[ __ ] jammed if you're going to do
something do it now what throw the
condom Adam we have no options other
than unable to think of anything Leon
fixes the mp5 and unloads 20 rounds into
your head should we use the condom yes
use the condom well maybe but not quite
what I had in mind
unfortunately pocket that monstrosity
and continue onwards dance like we're
gonna okay so far
eze item we gotta use everything we have
okay try thinking quickly you pull your
phone and whip it at Leon striking him
in the head the blow days is him
momentarily and you grab the Mossberg
and level it at him oh [ __ ]
that worked now you drop it [ __ ] or
I'll make your head disappear
you say evenly Leon looks in your eyes
and sees it you're dead serious he drops
the mp5 listen don't kill me I'm sorry
about he begins you're sorry you're
[ __ ] sorry
you just killed our best friend and call
blood and you're sorry I have to kill
you don't you see please Dom don't kill
me I swear I he please shut the [ __ ] up
you scream at him shut the [ __ ] up I
don't want to hear your lies anymore you
hear a voice whispering that if you let
him live he'll come after you that he
killed your best friend and deserves and
deserves vengeance no well no you can
escape cleaning and this horrible pass
for all time all you have to do is pull
this trigger it's time to make a
decision
kill her mister he was just about to
kill us
okay then kill him okay then do it
alright come on shoot him in the face in
Mossberg Wow
thinking of all the pain Leon has caused
you empty the Mossberg into his head and
chest your face called your eyes distant
but inside something is laughing as
Leon's eyes explodes and the shell
relates his flesh know with a horrified
expression on his face across the living
room floor searching surgeon and other
Russians you come up with nearly five
thousand cash pocketing it you take one
last look at Leon before turning away
you walk over to Ray and brush his hair
from his face sorry ray if only I had
known thank you kissing your finger and
placing it against his cheek briefly
that moment marks the end of your sanity
oh [ __ ] slinging the Mossberg over your
shoulder you pick up Ray's beretta stash
them in your pants and head for the
front door cops sirens scream in the
distance but you stride serenely into
the car even chuckling a bit to yourself
so you've lost it you're not wanted in
Missouri at least I hope you aren't but
you know but you know you can never go
back you practice your your practice
your relationship with Stacey your whole
life there has finished killing Serge
and his armies one thing but killing a
friend a defenseless one at that
was let's try the last trial on your
sanity a calden brutal creature you
become unfit for normal life and YC is
no longer home either as both of your
friends are dead getting into Liana's
car where he left the keys for a quick
getaway you read the engine and speed
off into the night failing to find your
destiny you did well I think we finished
you did well and perhaps you will find
it extremely frustrating to find out
that without the tell talisman you
cannot continue you cannot end this
story or any story if your destiny is
unfulfilled and unfulfilled it is this
web of lies leads to another and without
being able to follow that strand
everything is meaningless the breakdown
a hundred out of a hundred year level of
psychosis we were not spam
we lost our mind completely zero out of
ten our psychedelic state I don't know
what that means like we're not we
weren't high or something we voice takes
over the whole time maybe no 95 at a
hundred-year level of sobriety so we
pretty much worse over the whole time
except for the plane your total score is
659 out of a thousand your title is I
try my best you achieved no ending
because the universe refuses to let you
progress you were asleep
and this story but a dream and a greater
reality you cannot fathom Wow wait click
on try try again that's that's the only
thing that it says and then it takes you
back to the beginning are you kidding me
Wow how dude it was really fun and cool
but like I was now I'm in a like a
time-suck where I feel like I want to
play it again until we get it right I
kind of do too because there are so many
different points where we could have
done different things yeah that's weak
so I'm not so when Ray looked at you in
the apartment before you went to do the
raid like he was trying to tell you like
he knew mm-hmm and he wanted to help or
he wanted to like help I let me know but
Leon has always been [ __ ] nuts dude
cuz he's still your sober but Leon's
clearly not he had heroin needles in his
apartment
dude that [ __ ] was crazy wow what a
journey it has been my goodness
damn dude
the MVP of that story is the pitbull Flo
for sure yeah
poor guy poor guy hopefully he'll be ok
I can only hope so
[ __ ] Dom [ __ ] ray [ __ ] Leon hopefully
the pitbulls okay it's a pretty cool
thing to do like if you guys ever want
to go on that website and play those
games it's like it's really fun really
liked it a lot yeah I mean it's I knew
it was gonna be long but it did feel
like at times you're like where is this
guy you know I mean because especially
like the way they detail certain things
like they were spending a whole page
detailing a room that you're just like
okay yeah I get it it's gray yeah you
know but no it was cool if it felt like
damn I want to make it better
probably not be a piece of [ __ ] so if
you if you think we hadn't ran from the
cops this would have we would have been
better Oh probably what do you think
would have happened I don't know you you
probably would have gotten to work I
still had that run-in with Antonio cuz
he used to only said that's fine we
wouldn't have killed him no but he
probably would have still punched you
that's fine
but then I don't know I don't know oh
but remember Leon got into your
apartment because Stacy was gone
Stacy's gone she's got it going on
alright yeah I definitely shouldn't have
run from her house but honestly if you
asked me if I wanted hops in a story
like this do it um will link the site
below but it's really fun hopefully you
guys enjoyed this I know this was a bit
different pacing and such from our
normal podcast but hopefully you guys
liked it and also I know that a lot of
you guys like this stuff and have better
you know stories and sites so share that
please because we're up for doing more
of these if you guys are keen yeah it's
fine well we [ __ ] up and we died we
stayed sober though over bounine Aires
they just can't make it through this
story it's just stay sober and
everything will end up it's not about
you a lesson just gets lose your mind
well have a great week don't goes coco
insane and in yeah no drugs no violence
[Music]
you